bonjour
Eric Poncet bonjour À combien de
tentatives d'assassinat ciblés à échappé
Vladimir Poutine c'est une excellente
question souvent quand j'ai un
journaliste affûté en face de moi je me
permets alors je pourrais vous donner un
chiffre mais ce serait faux forcément
extrêmement de chance je pense que c'est
plusieurs dizaines il y a forcément des
projets particulièrement depuis le
déclenchement de du conflit en Ukraine
en 2014 puis le renouveau de ce conflit
en 2022 il y a forcément des gens en
Russie et ailleurs qui souhaitent
l'éliminer mais il y a visiblement pas
eu de tentatives qui aboutit sous les
projecteurs ou enfin qui est presque
abouti sous les projecteurs on n'a pas
vu de moments de tension il y a eu des
rumeurs il y a eu des informations il y
a des il y a des hypothèses il y a des
rumeurs évidemment forcément sur les
fils télégrammes notamment des des
pro-ukrainiens il y a à chaque fois
qu'un drone s'approche du Kremlin ou de
Moscou on dit voilà ils veulent essayer
de taper le bunker de Vladimir Poutine
le fameux mais en fait venir ma Poutine
ne dort pas aux Kremlin donc il y a des
rumeurs qui sont fausses aussi alors
justement
la question que je voulais vous poser
vous me tendez la perche est-ce que
l'attaque du Kremlin il y a quelques
semaines en tous les cas ce qu'on a été
présenté comme une attaque du au-dessus
du Kremlin et puis les frappes évoquées
au début de la semaine sont derrière ces
frappes derrière ces rumeurs est-ce que
il y a des tentatives d'assassinat
ciblées alors ce qu'on a vu très
récemment et ce qu'on avait vu aussi sur
le toit du Kremlin pour moi c'était pas
des tentatives d'assassinat ciblé
puisque visiblement les drones étaient
programmés juste pour pour faire une
sorte de spectacle malheureusement pour
faire un symbole c'est à dire toucher le
symbole du pouvoir russe on a vu tous
ces images avec la fumée noire qui
s'élève à côté du drapeau russe sur sur
le Kremlin c'est évidemment des images
qui sont très marquantes par contre à la
fois pour le public étranger mais
surtout pour le public russe qui lui
voit que la guerre
de nouveau dans sur son territoire et
non pas seulement en Ukraine
il y a eu quand en tout cas à vous lire
il y a bien eu un dispositif côté
ukrainien pour faire des assassinats
ciblés tout à fait il existe toujours et
ils ont réussi pour certains et leurs
ils ont réussi pour certains puisque on
se souvient qu'au début du conflit
notamment les Ukrainiens ont réussi avec
leurs alliés évidemment pour notamment
les Américains qui fournissent
énormément de renseignements en ce sens
à abattre 5 généraux et amiraux russes
de premier plan c'est à dire qu'ils ont
vraiment complètement désorganisé le
front au début dans les premières
semaines de de l'offensive russe et ils
ont réussi à décapiter en fait des des
kilomètres et des kilomètres de front
qui n'avaient plus de commandement donc
évidemment il était compliqué pour les
Russes de poursuivre leur percée sans
avoir un commandant sur place
côté russe est-ce qu'on a cherché à
éliminer Zelinski c'est une bonne
question aussi il semble que à un des
moments dans les premières heures de
l'attaque il y a eu des mouvements de
troupes des tentatives de s'approcher de
la résidence de la présidence
ukrainienne mais je pense que si les
Russes avaient vraiment voulu aller au
bout ils auraient réussi ils ont ils ont
énormément de moyens
je pense que le moment de bascule
lorsque les l'assaut héliportées russes
n'a pas réussi à atteindre l'aéroport de
Kiev peut-être que d'autres objectifs
ont été rétrogradés
rétrograder pour l'instant est-ce que
les Russes utilisent dans tous les cas
la méthode et en particulier la méthode
des assassinats ciblées oui les Russes
sont habitués de cette méthode là on
peut souvenir par exemple que lorsqu'ils
envahi l'Afghanistan
dans les années 70 ils sont allés
exécuter le président de l'Afghanistan à
Kaboul comme tout premier acte de cette
guerre
ils ont exécuté le président afghan pour
ensuite pouvoir envahir le pays plus
librement c'est ça qui est très
intéressant vous lire c'est que les
prédécesseurs des Russes ont été très
friands très très friands de la de la
technique de l'assassination oui oui
avec avec Israël c'est un des pays qui a
une des plus grandes traditions dans ce
domaine-là et je pense qu'on peut le
rattacher à cette doctrine militaire
russe qui est que la vie d'un soldat ou
d'une personne n'a pas forcément
beaucoup de valeur ce qui compte c'est
la masse et c'est l'effet général que
l'on que l'on déclenche
on va y revenir justement parce que
votre livre pose une question
intéressante de tout au long de
l'ouvrage du début à la fin sur l'effet
réel et profond de la station de La
ciblée votre livre en tout cas est
passionnant il remonte dans l'histoire
il tourne autour de cette notion il pose
cette question lancinante mais à quoi
sert donc un assassinat ciblé et donc je
vais essayer d'y répondre mais
j'y répondez vous y répondez quand même
dans votre dans votre livre oui la
réponse est variable c'est à dire que
dans certains cas ça ne sert à rien voir
ça empire la situation et dans d'autres
ça n'a pas d'effet sur le terrain mais
c'est un effet pour l'évolution d'un
conflit de manière plus générale donc ça
a quand même un effet sur l'histoire on
peut citer par exemple l'assassinat de
Pompée par les Égyptiens c'est César
avait donc défait général romain pompé
qui s'était qui s'était rebeller et
pomper avait fui en Égypte le et les
Égyptiens fidèles à César avait
assassiné pompé finalement sur le
terrain ça n'a pas eu beaucoup
d'incidences puisque pomper avait déjà
perdu mais le fait que les Égyptiens
aient assassiné pompé ça a tellement
énervé ses arc il a mis Cléopâtre à la
place de la dynastie qui a régnait
les champions du procédé vous le disiez
donc ce sont les Israéliens pourtant ils
ont eu des ratés majeurs et les raté
majeur ça a été leurs bêtes noires
Yasser Arafat tout à fait il y a ça
Arafat ils ont failli faire en plus une
bavure monumentale puisque ils ont
failli à base en 198 exactement la
viande de son frère qui était médecin et
qui voyageait avec des enfants vers
l'Egypte et le Mossad était convaincu
que c'était il y a sarafat qui était à
bord les F-15 israéliens donc les avions
de chasse sont allés à sa rencontre
au-dessus de la Méditerranée ils ont
demandé le feu vert pour la battre et le
Mossad a donné son feu vert mais le
l'officier de l'armée de l'air
israélienne qui était en Israël n'a pas
donné son feu vert il sentait quelque
chose n'était pas normal il a il a
temporisé un peu il a passé des coups de
fil il a demandé il a dit mais enfin il
y a quelque chose de pas normal
là-dedans et finalement au bout de
quelques dizaines de minutes le Mossa de
la rappeler en disant peut-être un truc
bizarre et effectivement c'était le
frère de Yasser Arafat qui était dans
l'avion qui avait été
identifié par les agents du maussade à
l'aéroport comme étant bien il y a sa
Arafat ce qui était une erreur et donc
là le Mossad a évité une bavure
monumentale dans lequel ils auraient tué
des dizaines d'enfants les Américains
aussi sont très friands du procédé tout
à fait et encore aujourd'hui oui oui
encore aujourd'hui les américains ils
ont même institutionnalisé le la
pratique puisque c'est
oui bien sûr on pense à Ben Laden donc
la pratique elle a été largement relancé
en deux après les attentats de 2001 mais
donc c'est George Bush qui a junior qui
a lancé ça mais c'est surtout Barack
Obama qui a un mois après avoir obtenu
son prix Nobel de la Paix a signé la
disposition et la disposition qui
s'appelle Matrix qui autorise de manière
systématique ces assassinats ciblées
les Français dans
ce
dans ce cadre et par rapport à cette
technique
on a à savoir ce qui est vrai ce qui est
faux
est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas est-ce que quand
même d'abord les Français et ça c'est
sur un dernier point j'aimerais avoir
votre votre point de vue ce qui se sont
pas appuyés sur le savoir-faire
américain notamment pour venger la mort
de l'agent français l'agent de la DGSE
française dans les tous premiers jours
d'ailleurs de la guerre au Mali même si
c'était la
en Somalie
la mort de Denis alex je vous cite
c'était une anecdote des responsables de
DGSE qui m'avait dit oui nous avons dit
à la famille de Denis Alex cette
anaassinat cette mort ne sera pas ne
restera pas un puni alors je pense
qu'effectivement lorsqu'un des leurres
est touché la DGSE et particulièrement
active mais comme ne le serait tout tout
service j'imagine et là ils ont activé
tout leur partenariat enfin c'est très
difficile de lire dans les actions de la
DGSE et comme comme le dit mon illustre
confrère Jean Guinel la DGSE tout ce
qu'elle peut cacher pour le reste elle
s'est ouverte mais mais non non
évidemment ils ont ils ont activé les
partenariats avec les Américains et il y
a eu des présages alors l'un des grands
arguments pour lire votre livre c'est
que c'est bourré de révélation et on
apprend notamment mais c'est pas la
seule c'est pour ça je me permets de
donner celle là que les services
français avaient Nasser parmi leurs
cibles oui tout à fait il voulait
éliminer Nasser à la suite de de du flop
monumental de l'opération mousquetaires
avec les Britanniques
les Français voulaient éliminer Nasser
et visiblement comme pour leur reprise
du canal de Suez il y a eu des coups de
fil assez tendus entre entre les alliés
occidentaux
on apprend que
surtout on vous lisant que l'assassinat
ciblée c'est quand même un art si je
puis dire délicat oui il y a souvent des
choses qui se passent mal
c'est une citation d'un d'un ancien
militaire allemand mais qui dit voilà le
le meilleur des plans de résistent pas
au contact avec l'ennemi et ça se révèle
particulièrement vrai
qui disaient les le premier mort en
opération c'est le plan d'opération
exactement c'est tout à fait ça c'est
pareil dans les assassinations dans les
assassinats ciblés il y a toujours
quelque chose qui se passe pas comme
prévu mais comme dans comme dans tout
plan mais là c'est souvent dans la mort
de Ben Laden exactement dans la mort de
Ben Laden il y a l'hélicoptère qui
effectue ce qu'on appelle un posé dur
donc qui qui se crash pas vraiment mais
qui touche tellement plus fort le sol à
l'atterrissage qui peut plus en décoller
donc ils sont obligés de le faire
exploser avant de repartir ils sont
obligés d'appeler un autre hélicoptère
qui lui n'est pas furtif pour ramasser
un maximum de de documents et d'éléments
qui sont qui sont pris dans la maison
donc voilà il y a beaucoup de choses qui
se passent mal on pense aussi à
l'assassinat de haydrich à Prague le
responsable nazi qui est le seul
assassinat d'ailleurs d'un responsable
nazi pendant les 2e guerre mondiale la
mitrailleuse s'enraye et en plus le
monsieur est en retard puisqu'il a joué
plus longtemps que d'habitude avec ses
enfants ce matin là ah ouais il y a
tellement d'éléments qui peuvent se
passer de manière imprévue je vais très
compliqué je vous cite guéri le
traitement médiatique des assassinats
ciblés est parfait exemple de la
subjectivité des journalistes pourquoi
Monsieur l'ancien président de
l'Association des journalistes de
défense
c'est très délicat parce que selon d'où
vient l'assassinat ciblé il n'aura pas
le traitement médiatique le même
traitement médiatique évidemment que un
assassinat ciblé d'un Oussama Ben Laden
ou d'un terroriste
tout terroriste qu'il soit en théorie il
a droit à un procès mais on a tendance
quand même dans les médias occidentaux à
évacuer le fait de pas voir de pas
vouloir regarder en face le fait que on
court circuit totalement le système
judiciaire qui est les fondements de nos
démocraties même si évidemment on peut
argumenter en disant qu'on ne peut pas
combattre le terrorisme en se fondant
uniquement sur le système judiciaire y
compris quand on opèrent à l'étranger je
reviens à une autre question justement
sur sa est-ce que la France pratique des
assassinats ciblées oui la France
pratique des assassinats ciblées elle
l'a montré l'état-major a toujours des
lentilles l'état-major des mots mais on
a quand même un ancien président qui l'a
reconnu dans un dans un livre qui avait
fait beaucoup de bruit à l'époque
président ne devrait pas dire ça c'est
exactement et puis on constate sur le
terrain même le fait que les forces
spéciales soient encore présentes au
Sahel le montre bien alors ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est que c'est un peu
cruel de fabrique comme ça mais
l'assassinat ciblé c'est un moteur
d'innovation technologique et en
particulier au niveau des drones ouais
et des drones armés exactement et c'est
l'assassinat ciblé permet de développer
notamment dans les entreprises
israéliennes
des tirs très précis
que les Israéliens étaient capables de
faire je crois que c'est le chat qui a
signé ou qui était assassin qui a été
abattu par un missile oui tout à fait et
donc ils arrivent maintenant avec les
nouveaux systèmes de GPS plus performant
à avoir quelques dizaines de centimètres
de marge et non plus 2 à 3 mètres et
donc ça ça permet de cibler de façon
très précise avec des nouveaux missiles
aussi et puis avec des nouveaux des
nouveaux moyens de surveillance des
nouveaux moyens d'interception des
communications qui permettent aussi de
vérifier que la cible est bien la cible
etc et puis le summum presque c'est les
Américains qui ont développé un nouveau
missile qui n'explose pas mais qui
déploie des lames autour de lui et ils
sont tellement sûrs d'arriver à quelques
centimètres de leur cible qui se
contente d'une lame qui sort du missile
au moment de l'impact pour pour
déchiqueter le corps de la cible est-ce
qu'il y a une tentative d'assassinat
ciblée en 2011 quand le convoi de mon
marque adefi a été visée notamment par
un Mirage français ça c'est c'est une
probabilité effectivement alors Kadhafi
c'est avec Yasser Araf je pense une des
personnes qui a échappé à plus de au
plus grand nombre de tentatives
d'assassinat ciblées puisqu'on en
connaît au moins une de la part des
Américains et puis il y en a une
suspectée au dessus de la Méditerranée
dans son avion qui avait mené au crash
d'un appareil civil de d'un avion de
ligne italien
vous imaginez d'ailleurs de nouvelles
générations d'armes pour pour des
assassinats ciblées ça fait froid dans
le lot mais notamment vous imaginez une
présidente française qui serait
assassiné par des blattes en fait c'est
pas des blattes c'est des mini drônes
qui se mettrai dans l'avion présidentiel
tout à fait alors ça c'est c'est bon
c'est évidemment un fantasme des films
de science-fiction mais aujourd'hui on
arrive à une telle miniaturisation et
une telle autonomisation des ce qu'on
appellerait des robots mais qui
finalement sont des des petites machines
qu'on peut imaginer tout à fait d'avoir
des insectes qui qui répondent d'un gaz
ou explosent au visage d'une cible
lyrics sera ma dernière question
l'objectif de l'assassinat ciblé on lit
dans votre livre c'est touché le cerveau
c'est de faire exploser le dispositif et
quand on vous lit quand on lit
l'histoire d'un certain nombre
d'assassinat ciblés quand on voit la
guerre en Ukraine on se pose une autre
question est-ce que l'assassinat ciblé
n'est pas plus efficace quand il touche
le cœur plutôt que quand il touche le
cerveau c'est à dire que quand il touche
le moral des troupes plus que le cœur
d'un dispositif et bien je pense que la
réponse est effectivement que c'est plus
efficace quand ça touche le cœur puisque
on l'a vu l'exemple parfait c'est
l'assassinat de l'amiraliyamamoto
l'amiral japonais qui était le cerveau
de Pearl Harbor finalement sur le
terrain quand les Américains l'ont
abattu et l'ont exécuté en faisant une
patrouille d'interception de 1600 km à
travers le Pacifique et bien ils ont
plus touché le moral des Américains en
positif et le moral des Japonais en
négatif que finalement changer le cours
des choses sur le plan opérationnel le
mort la mort fantôme l'assassinat ciblé
comme ARN de guerre ça se lit très vite
c'est extrêmement bien écrit normal
c'est un confrère très affûté et c'est
plein d'anecdotes historiques de
scénario futuristes en un mot c'est
passionnant merci beaucoup guérite
Poncet inutile de dire qu'on recommande
la lecture on recommande la lecture
également de la nouvelle note de Xavier
DRIANCOURT de la nouvelle note de la
Fonda Paul elle revient sur une question
et un accord qui est peu connu mais
cette question qui est soulevée c'est
celle de la difficulté de faire exécuter
les obligations de quitter le territoire
français de la part du pouvoir algérien
avant de revenir avec Xavier encore on a
posé la question au monsieur immigration
DLR Patrick Stefanini pour savoir lui
quel était sa recette pour pouvoir
justement faire en sorte que l'Algérie
respecte ses obligations